guys we got the dates for 2023 locked
maybe a couple more added La Jolla I'll
be back October 20th through the 22nd
Salt Lake City finally coming back
October 27th and the 28th hoping to see
you all out there Batavia Illinois my
first time going there very excited
coming on November 10th and November
11th and San Francisco to close out the
year at Cobbs cannot wait to get back to
one of my favorite cities in the country
December 8th and 9th all tickets are
available on my website at
ryansickler.com
guys the audio for my special Lefty son
is out I've released it as an album it
is available on audio everywhere iTunes
Spotify you name it it's out there go
check it out and support my special on
YouTube thank you
I'm very excited to announce that we
have partnered with Spotify it changes
absolutely nothing for you the added
benefit though is that you now get video
on Spotify you're gonna get the Honeydew
audio and video on Spotify we're very
excited to partner with Spotify it
changes absolutely nothing for you
you're not having to pay for anything or
anything nothing's behind a paywall none
of that you just now able to get audio
and video
on Spotify so go subscribe to the
Honeydew on Spotify today the Honeydew
with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
I say thank you every week thank you to
everybody who watches this show supports
this show listens to the show
um whether you're new here or whether
you've been here thank you for your
support please subscribe to the YouTube
channel and um if you gotta have more
then I'm telling you I say it every week
and you listen because every week the
subscribers go up you gotta check out
the patreon the patreon's called the
Honeydew with y'all and it's this exact
show with y'all and y'all have the
wildest [__] stories out there I
promise you five bucks a month is all it
is there's no levels and tears and it's
five dollars and you get hundreds of
episodes of the Y wildest stories you've
ever heard in your life alright now if
you or someone you know has a story
that's got to be heard please submit it
to honeydew podcast gmail.com and if
you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to again check out my old podcast
the crab Feast it's a seven and a half
year library of every single person you
know and love in podcasting segora
Christina Burt Bill Burr all of them
they're all out there so check that out
and come see me on tour if I'm in your
city when you're around October 20th to
the 22nd I'll be in La Jolla California
October 27th and 28th Salt Lake City
Utah November 10th and 11th Batavia
Illinois on December 8th and the 9th San
Francisco California all right that's
everything there you know what we're
doing over here we're highlighting the
low lights and I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
I'm very excited to have this guest on
first time here on the Honeydew ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome Andrea gin
welcome to the Honeydew hi thank you for
having me thank you for being here I'm
excited to be here well I've never met
you before and you came in right away
with the energy and you passed a
princess litmus test out there she she
loves me now loves you yeah she crossed
over me three times yeah you're on the
good list
um well before we get into what we're
going to talk about today please plug
promote everything and anything you'd
like yeah I'm on tour right now I'm
doing a Texas Run San Antonio Addison uh
Houston Austin I'm doing Bloomington and
Philly Springfield Ohio I'm doing round
you're all over I'm doing everything
Kansas City's both Springfields and
Virginia Beach so
and then some others Utah I'm doing Utah
as well in Vegas
and where can they get tickets oh yeah
right I'm like just think about it just
think about going
just I have an intention
um they can get tickets at andreajin.com
all right yeah and your social media
your Instagram yeah at Andrea gin and
you actually got it so you're I did yeah
you're lucky you know I got another line
for all of them really what is yours
there's all the Ryan sicklers out there
that beat me to the punch on social
media names yeah what's your handle then
most of them are Ryan sickler but I've
got to have like an official I think on
Facebook and dumb stuff like that you
know official uh yeah thank you for
coaching me through that plug I I really
wasn't do you have a podcast or anything
you'd like to promote okay so dates for
sure go check out andreogen.com and
follow you on social media
Andrea andreogen1 on Tick Tock see
that's the kind of [__] on top
that's the kind of [__] I'll talk about
I'm pissed you could tell which social
media you had first and what you got
most recent by the additional ones and
[__] like that too I got Andrew Jim
first yeah The Tick Tock last oh [__]
all right
we were talking earlier and I know
Martin researched you and did some uh
looking into your background so I really
want to talk to you because you were
born in China right yes you come here at
10. yes so can we talk about life in
China first and what you do remember of
it oh my God you have to remember at
least I remember four or five years so
much so much I remember so much like
China's such it's so in my blood and my
DNA like in my upbringing my programming
really uh
yeah
we're already getting [__] for this
episode
right there we're done so fast
I'm like the Chinese government the
Chinese government
oh my God okay wait so where in China
are you were you born I was born in
Shanghai okay yeah but my whole family
were from uh Northeast China yeah it's
like near North Korea okay uh but Jesus
I know all the buzzwords yeah
it's gonna be the most dangerous at
rated episode we've ever
like that is a dangerous episode the
title is like don't watch this don't
watch this episode
yeah no so uh yeah Shanghai Shanghai was
great I when I was born my mom just
suddenly I don't think she liked being a
mother
so why do you say that because she left
right away
[Laughter]
that's a damn good indicator
oh okay all right so wait let me ask a
question then yeah are you an only child
yes all right I was born under the one
child policy it's an actual policy when
you were born what year were you born
96. so just as recent as 96 is that
still on the thing no now they lifted it
because they realized uh if they keep
going Chinese the Chinese population
would dip too much like we would become
non-existent or something so if every
person only had one child eventually
over time it would just dip way too much
to a point where we're not comfortable
or it can't be a superpower a military
yeah
I gotta hit all the points okay so
really there's a policy it's it's one
child only yeah back then and how do
they know I mean I guess you got to
register yeah yeah yeah there's
definitely illegal like people have them
on the and hide their kids out in the
farm you can have more than one but you
have to pay like heavy taxes for it for
for the extra kids so only rich people
can afford uh extra children so your Mom
leaves right away and you're raised by
your dad my dad also no nobody liked me
don't say that my my parents got
divorced um they both went so okay so
it's actually very complicated because
my mom married my dad and then uh
she didn't have me with him
she had me out of marriage okay so
you're
biological fathers and wasn't your
mother's husband yes my birth father is
someone else your mom had a side dude
yes yeah she yeah so she's a city girl
but all right she but so this guy Shang
lo you know what I'm saying
and she uh but they both went to
Vancouver I see yeah they wanted to
immigrate so then they both went to
Vancouver after having me so my
grandparents raised me all right so did
they divorce at what how old were you
when they finally split I was maybe I
was like a baby okay yeah it was a baby
so where is your biological father does
he stay in China was he even in China he
was he was in Northeast China okay so
does he stay there when your mom goes to
Vancouver
he well he's always lived there he's
always lived in Northeast China and he
continues to be there and my mom wait
what do you mean I mean your biological
father is not your mother's husband was
yes so those two went to Vancouver your
husband and wife went to Vegas yes the
husband and wife went to that Dad stays
in China the biological dad has a
marriage of his own oh [__] he's got a
whole family yeah no he's not just a
single dude no got it okay all right I'm
thinking in my mind he's a just a
multi-stand or both cheating okay two
cheaters okay that's what
yeah and both sides you come out of this
I come out of the um but you're also
going to Vancouver I'm I went when I was
10. so they went first the the husband
and wife went first got it and raised by
your grandparents raised by my
grandparents in China okay and let's
talk about that before we get to 10.
what was that like because I also live
with my grandmother for a while really
yeah I mean we're Italian-American
extended families kind of a big deal
also when you're a broken [__]
family's necessary so exactly you know
what I relate to Italians a lot actually
yeah I grew up watching like uh all the
Italian movies like God Godfather and
like Goodfellas and everything I related
to the family Dynamics everybody yelling
at each other you know the closest
dysfunction it's so dysfunctional but I
I always loved yeah I felt related to
Italian culture but uh yeah so
it was like school there was very strict
you know
um we learned a lot in the beginning
like I was learning like times tables
when I was in preschool and like
kindergarten yeah that's how we got
ahead yeah oh [__] you guys are dusting
us yeah everyone is by the way no
offense everybody's kicking our ass it
is true yeah but but um
yeah I remember just like you know
saluting the flag every day uh every
morning for school our uniforms and like
um doing math and my grandpa my grandpa
like sitting in the back of his bike
while we like you know go to school and
stuff it was really nice it felt like
like a farm or something even though I
was in Shanghai it was like a major city
so it was really nice
and what were your grandparents like and
whose parents are these moms they're my
mom's parents and they wanted her to get
rid of me because I wasn't in made in
the marriage
um but she wanted to have me and so we
yeah so it was weird like knowing that
can I just say this is kind of wild as
you're saying this I'm thinking of this
like your mom wanted to have you but
didn't want to keep you yeah the
grandparents didn't want to have you but
kept you yeah it's [__] wild isn't
that weird like just what happened did
you ever I mean have you do you still
are they still alive your grandpa yeah
yeah have you ever had a talk with them
about like what made you guys flip and
take me and were they good did they love
you did they nurture you and take it
they loved me so much like the love that
they they taught me I mean
the the way that my mom loves me is kind
of [__] up
so I shouldn't learn from that but the
love that my grandparents taught me
that's real you know that's like
unconditional so uh yeah they really did
they really yeah what are some of your
Fondest Memories and being with your
grandparents yeah I we had like so many
animals for some reason like because we
they like Northeast China there's a lot
of farms and stuff like my grandparents
they both grew up in like rural
backgrounds and uh so my mom my grand my
grandma always loved having chickens so
we would have like chicks in the
backyard I played with chicks we had
bunnies yeah we had yeah right well she
has chickens now really yeah yeah in
Vancouver there's chickens and they lay
it she just loves the eggs she loves
having her own eggs and uh we had a
snake at one point you know and we just
there were just a lot of animals around
I remember hating math I always hated
school
my Grandpa would do my homework nah he
would he did wasn't good at it he sucked
I got so mad at him I was
no the thing is no this [__] is
a show-off okay so he here's the thing
he was so smart growing up like he
taught himself like he went to
University like nobody else did in my
family and he became an electrical
engineer and he's like very proud of
that you know so he's like out here
doing like very complicated math for
this like kindergartner like grade one
person like he's doing like he's just
putting a flare on my homework and then
my teacher was like she knew right away
she's like you didn't do this and then
she walked into I remember this so well
because it was so scary it was like a
core memory she walked into my English
lesson or yeah English class because we
were learning English in China and um
my math teacher I remember she was
pregnant too she was so angry she was
like like well she didn't call me Andrea
but my Chinese name she was like did I
need to talk to you and I was like okay
she's like did someone do your homework
can you say that in Chinese does that
sound scarier than English
I forgot exactly what she said I just
remembered the anger you know loud too
that she pulled you out of class or she
embarrassed you in front of you oh [__]
the pregnant [__]
she was so pregnant I'm like go home go
have your baby
yeah grab your one baby stop being angry
at work
let me not find out that your second
baby I'll report you you report me to
the class everywhere so just embarrassed
you in front of the class you're not
cheating what was it like yeah it was
like oh someone someone did your
homework who did your homework you're
you're like your cousin like who did it
and then I was like no I didn't mean I'm
crying in class I'm crying and then uh
eventually I was like my grandpa did it
and then she uh yeah I was in a lot of
trouble
but that was my grandpa's fault why did
he have to do my homework uh all [__]
show offy and [__] anyway
um they babyed me a lot
they babyed me a lot like I was such
yeah everything they just like because
they felt bad for me they say that to me
now they said we just gave you whatever
you wanted because we felt bad your mom
wasn't there you know uh I remember just
like I loved getting under the table and
like during dinner time and just being a
brat and not eating dinner my my grandma
would like chased me around and like
feed me
um
but yeah school was
you had to like sit up stray occupy one
third of the chair put your like hand
what's that mean like not be too
comfortable I think like just so you
gotta slide your ass like more toward
the edge of the seat oh really like I
for some reason deep space back there
yeah and they would monitor that if you
did like if you were slouching they
would come by and tell you get nah
really yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta sit
straight like this and have like good
posture and we we we would do um
uh like breaks from studying with eye
massage exercises we would do them as a
school the whole school did it together
we'll get rid of these bags under mine
to make sure that you to exercise your
eyes so that you can study longer
it's to utilize yeah to keep the machine
going longer yeah we would do these
breaks like like twice a day you know
just like be on the announcement so like
all right time for you know eye massage
and then we would just do it together
yeah the whole school gently massage
your eyes yeah it was I still remember
it was like
um it's like this and then this and then
this so like it was a routine we all
knew it it would just be maybe like
two minutes or something yeah yeah and
then it's back to the world back to
studying yeah back to you know yeah so
it was very intense I really hated it I
really like there was a also
um a system where you have like class
captains and stuff
uh like the best students in in class
they we had rankings so you did like
this is there an indicator on your
clothes yeah yeah there's like Captain
and [__] or something no it was like
three strikes like uh like three the
like military kind of yeah it was very
military the way like school was run
um it would be a badge one person had a
batch with three strikes on it she's
like the leader I remember ours she was
this girl she was very athletic and she
was perfect I could never do the three I
only had the highest I went was two yeah
so there's two two strike people and
then there's like a couple one yeah and
but those are like the class
leaders yeah okay
yeah
um I want to ask you this 10 years
that's a very formidable uh time in in
your young life
do you find today since your
grandparents are still alive that you
have
picked up anything from your grandfather
or grandmother like I'm a certain way
because of this or that and and if so
what oh my God yeah by an older
generation which is always interesting
to me like I still if I see an old lady
anywhere I'll chat him up like my
grandmother and her sisters were just
they you know what I mean like I just
still feel like
I tried I say I try to do things in my
mind where I'm like oh my well my
grandmother be mad if I did that you
know what I mean I'm 50 and I still
think like that that's great you know I
talk to old people all the time like I
love them uh because of my grandparents
for sure I just like feel something for
them if I see a old person alone it
breaks my heart I like just wanna take
them somewhere so in what ways do you
like your grandparents yeah so my
grandpa is
they're both my grandpa is such an act
of service and gift-giving love language
guy because he will never say anything
sentimental he would never show or touch
like you know like affectionately you
know
um so every time I would struggle with
something like he would see I'm upset he
would go buy a fish for for me to have
for dinner you know and not even give it
to me give it to my grandma and it's
like oh cook it and then my Grandma will
be like your Grandpa got you fish so
because you were crying earlier and then
I would just be like oh my God like my
grandpa loves me you know uh but I got
that from him probably just like acts of
service and showing love through acts of
service and like gift giving but not
being being uncomfortable being a little
uncomfortable with like too much words
of affection or like you know with with
certain people yeah so again nervous
about that and my grandma
she's someone that has like so much
anxiety she just like will think herself
to Oblivion and I've always I I think I
picked it up
for a period of time
and then eventually I I worked through
it because I don't do that anymore
um but for a while I I had her anxiety
and uh she she transfers it onto other
people too she'll tell me things that I
shouldn't really need to know as a
teenager like what what do you remember
your grandmom dropping on you were like
what the [__] she sure she would tell me
like my mom was doing drugs oh you know
oh she'll be like yeah like when I was
in China you know don't know where my
mom is like missing her and then she'll
show me pictures of my mom's like
partying or whatever and she'll be like
yeah your mom's doing drugs like you
know just things that I shouldn't really
have to know
um because she's so anxious she it
spills out you know and and then it it
affects me a lot
and it would every time even to this day
when my grandma calls me with a problem
uh
I I think about it for like two days or
something yeah so
so what happens at 10 that
makes you decide or who decides for you
to now to go to Vancouver yeah it was my
mom's decision I think it was at 10 I
think she was like oh she's probably not
annoying anymore I don't have to like do
deal with like diapers and whatnot did
she get clean at that point or it was
just more like you could sort of handle
yourself and I don't have to babysit
yeah literally right like me yeah
because she wants to go out and do her
thing oh yeah and you're a little older
now like you said no diapers yeah I
don't have to worry about putting you to
bed you can go to you know you can take
care of yourself yeah you know and she
exactly and she just thought I need I
should get to know my daughter like I
want I don't want a decade
exactly maybe I should get to know this
person that came out of my body you know
yeah exactly and so she thought it was
the person I wanted
I thought I wanted and she thought it
was time and so I'm uh she flew me over
there she took me away from my
grandparents and my school I remember
like just so upset my friends there you
had real love there yeah I had a life
there and my yeah leaving that
grandparents was really hard and I'm
assuming it was hard for them too
because this is their daughter who's
having all this trouble and as a parent
you know you gotta take that one yeah
and then here goes your granddaughter
now to go be with the person that that's
yeah yeah did you ever talk to your
grandparents about what it was like to
have a daughter who rejected or yeah a
daughter who rejected her own daughter
it's against Mother Nature I say I can I
only say it because my mom did the same
my mom bounced really yeah and that just
goes away against but you know what's
interesting
they did that to my mom
they did yeah so I think that connected
so much for me I see it because my
grandma she had three daughters and then
my mom was the middle one and it was too
overwhelming for her
she had the baby and then the bigger you
know and so she sent my mom away to her
sister so her auntie yeah yeah so she so
her aunt like raised my mom and then uh
just when it was time to come back to my
grandma she didn't want to she was like
that's not my mom my like my aunt is my
mom you know she was like like so this
happened to her too
so that's interesting questions yeah so
I feel like my grandparents have this
like
probably guilt towards my mom for
sending her away and then so they raised
them raising me was like
something yeah to do do with that all
right so now you're going to America you
know English though I'm assuming because
you've been taking it all those years
right but it's not great okay yeah I I
had like an accent I'm pretty sure I
didn't know I wasn't fluent yeah I
certainly wasn't comfortable speaking it
and so we
um
I got to Vancouver and it was crazy
because my mom was on another marriage
she was on her second marriage and this
guy I've never met and suddenly I had a
stepfather and then they have kids
they didn't have kids but he had his own
kids before this marriage so I had a
that he also brought into
um
he flew her from somewhere to I think
like China also so I suddenly had a
stepsister and a stepfather
and then all under the same roof yeah
yeah instantly and then my mom who I
like never really yeah you don't know
anybody yeah you don't know anyone in
this [__] I know how old's the
stepsister she was a year older than me
yeah
no she was like I think she was ESL too
yeah I remember yeah she I think she
came from also a part of China so and
you're sharing a room we're sharing a
room
no we're checking a bed no yeah yeah
yeah how big is the bed it's a queen
it don't matter it ain't a kick he went
from having your own room yeah well no I
was sharing a bed with my grandparents
like well you went from just living with
your grandparents to a new house where
you three new people you don't know and
one of them is literally laying next to
you I know that's [__] that's [__]
up and you know what's fine I wet the
bed till I I was still wetting the bed
when I left China so we were very
nervous about this I would have been
like listen I'll definitely get mine
I would
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
I was waiting in the bed in China and I
would wake up slapping I'd like I wonder
what like I would I have violent dreams
your grandma's taking you for breakfast
and just smacking the [__] out no my
grandma got so mad at me that she she
was like no I'm not doing this again and
she made my grandpa switch with uh with
her so I would just wake up just
slapping my grandpa my grandma's like
yes and wet too from the pee so which is
like how long did you wet the bed till I
moved to Vancouver I think it was a
psychological thing I think I was like
always coming yeah so I was that's old
oh [__] that's old no but like my
brothers were bedwetters too past ten
yeah a lot of people come on here and
talk about it it's called trauma okay
yeah you have it okay because I was like
I see because I didn't have a mom or dad
and now you're about to move to a place
where you don't know a [__] soul I'd
be peeing wow my body is just like stop
yeah there's a lot going on yeah so
anyway I did that until I it was
psychological because the second I
started sleeping near next to a stranger
who was now my stepsister I stopped
so because I didn't want to I guess be
embarrassed and so and I was just highly
uncomfortable isn't it funny like my
daughter's a picky eater and we and we
the doctors talk about like look and her
brother was too and they're like it's
gonna take care of itself the minute she
gets to high school and starts hanging
out with her friends and you're like you
don't eat this or this and that's all
you put on you only put ketchup on what
the [__] you know what I mean like it
shames you into eating and stuff yeah
exactly it's yeah it makes you realize
everything is psychological everything's
just in your head so she wasn't a bad
weather was she how hilarious would that
be like I don't know I just started this
is traumatic for me give it to her yeah
you passed it all
oh
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
do you ever feel like your brain is
getting in its own way like you know
what you should do what's good for you
but you just can't do it well therapy
helps you figure out what's holding you
back so you can work for yourself
instead of against yourself all right if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule you just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge look you know we
believe in therapy it's a big deal to
work out that mind and not just your
body if you need to talk to someone
please just talk to someone anyone give
it a try all right make your brain your
friend with better help visit
betterhelp.com honeydew today to get 10
off of your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew one more time
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew now let's get
back to the do so wait this is such a
weird situation do you get along with
her like do you guys develop a bond or
we bonded in some ways but I had so much
anger and Trauma in me I did not treat
her well I felt I feel to this day like
really bad about do you still talk no
okay I I don't know what she's doing and
and same with my stepdad I haven't
talked to them since my mom split with
him
and it I I just like
yeah you just don't know when it's
happening like as a kid why all this
anger with the hormones and the trauma
from you know anxiety you don't know
anything yeah he's mad and confused and
yeah I would fight with her all the time
it was like so much fighting and I just
hated we we had bonding moments for sure
and I think at the end of the day it was
fine did she like your mom
I don't think she loved I don't think
any of us loved each other you know it
was very put together like forcefully
because of this marriage and how long
did the marriage last
I think about
they had a whole thing before we came
but then once we got there
um two or three years and then they got
divorced because he cheated on her yeah
a lot of that going around but she yeah
that's true a lot of cheaters in here so
you're what about a freshman then maybe
going into high school when it's just
you and your mom at that point yeah yeah
and my grandparents thankfully came oh
they did they came over all right yeah
the story takes a good turn all right
good thank God it saved my life yes 10
years so far saved my life yeah it's
been a rough 14. oh my God same day they
come to Vancouver and they live and
they're in your day-to-day they're not
like two hours away or anything they're
in the home yeah oh in the home yes okay
so we're all living together now all
four of you live together and what's it
like God that probably had to be a very
big help to also get to know your mom
slowly too yeah yeah so how did it all
go was it did it start to turn around
there or it
my mom has always struggled with
addiction like with gambling that's her
biggest one oh it's gambling it's
gambling the drugs is part of just
partying when she wins or whatever
what's the game or anything uh it's
I forgot the name but she plays
Blackjack sometimes too yeah and she's
doing like online stuff with credit
cards no that almost
I don't even know what would be better
but she goes to the casino she does yeah
yeah and uh it's just
it's
her whole life her whole life it's been
like this
it's the biggest problem in our whole
family and she's got a blackjack
addiction yeah yeah and losing so just
how much do you even know Millions no
yes I was not expecting to hear that
yeah Andrea gin millions of dollars
she's lost yes has she ever hit big and
that's why she's got something to piss
away never what no
oh baby she hit a butt and then had
enough to piss away no where is she
getting this money what does she do you
know what she's she's very beautiful and
she's uh she's gorgeous and and it's
always just been
man yeah it's been that men will take
her and pay for the yeah pay for
everything give me a couple hundred
dollars I'm gonna go play Black not even
they give her they give her millions of
dollars like basically yeah like
basically no okay not that much but you
know this is her whole philosophy in
life is like if
if they don't give you money then they
don't love you
every thing is so transactional for her
she
but I love her very much this is this is
it it breaks my heart but
for her it's
uh this man one time that she was dating
uh wouldn't buy her an apartment in
Shanghai and then she she left him and
she was like oh well I'll go find
someone that would and then she found
someone that did so it's that's like a
good example it's just she's just kind
of looking for a provider nice right
so
um even when I call her to ask her how
are you and stuff
yeah come on we ain't stopping on 17.
let's go how you doing girl
no she'll literally be be confused why
I'm calling because she she'll think
well what do you need something because
it's not normal just to call and talk
and say hey yeah I'm thinking about you
exactly it's got to come with
transactional yeah like whenever she
only calls me when she needs something
got it and never to check in no no does
she know about your comedy does she
follow your career yeah anything has she
seen you live yes yeah she said I uh was
very tall
thank you
that was after the not walking in that
was after the show yes yeah that's good
she's you know she's like you need to
project more you know like a lot of
critiques but
um but yeah every time she calls is
always transactional it's always like
she needs something and she gets
confused if I call her and and I'm like
hey are you good and she's like
I think it's weird so
yeah so that's that's what's uh what's
your mom's relationship like now with
her parents or at least at that point
when they came into the home did it get
better or was it more of the same
I think she's always resented them for
sending her away
and but she's a good daughter like she
takes care of her my grandparents very
well like she's always
thinking of like take yeah she's always
I mean they still live together now in
Vancouver
and
yeah but I I can tell there's like anger
there and un dealt with trauma of being
sent away as a as a as a girl how would
your mom know she's 46 47 maybe it's
interesting I'm older than her I'm
trying to think about that I'd be
[__] pissed if I got sent away too
but I still wouldn't have leave my kid
yeah there's a lot of layers in there
but again she was taught that I think
she just thought it was okay because it
happened to her so she was like well
it's fine I'm fine even though she's not
like she just never dealt with her [__]
yeah so she thinks oh that's an okay way
to do things so she did it to me is she
with um does she have another husband or
a partner or boyfriend or anything now
or she's kind of single no she's single
and but she's thinking of she's been
talking to my birth father I think
that's the love of her life tell me
about that yeah they met when he was um
uh
when she was alive
that's true but also she was like a
teenager she was like 17. and then they
just like were they just connected very
deeply they're just kids yeah at the
time and they just really loved each
other and but do you know if they've
kept in touch all this time or is this a
new no way they did I've met him a lot
of times before she told me that he's my
birth father so he was always around but
he's always married and uh when my mom
was gonna get married to her husband
uh he said to her he was like don't
marry him I'll leave my wife for you
don't marry another man and she was like
no I'm not gonna wreck your I'm gonna
I'm not gonna be a homewrecker I'm not
gonna break up your family so she
married
um and but they've kept in touch like
forever but when she taught she never
cries
he's the only person that he's the only
topic that makes her like really ball so
so tell me what's the first time you met
your birth father how old were you
or at least how old were you when the
first time you remember meeting I'm sure
he saw you before
I remember this is a very actually bad
memory to have of my birth father but I
I remember the first memory of him is
him being in bed with my mom
because they met up at a hotel or
something but and I was so tiny I was
like a baby or something I was like a
toddler I remember just them being in
bed and I'm in the other room with like
an Auntie like not a real Auntie but
just like a friend of my mom's that she
brought along to take care of me while
they
um were together and I remember just
being like why is my mom in bed with
like some guy but yeah that that might
have been the first but we would go out
together and like eat and I just thought
it was some man that my mom liked yeah I
didn't know when did you find out who he
was
like during the pandemic no yes get the
[__] out get her oh my God I'm thinking
you're gonna say like 10 years old no
she she neglected to tell me so you
obviously knew that the husband you
never thought her husband at the time
was your dad you always knew it was
another person
no no she made me think that was my dad
oh she did yeah her husband
you've yes up until three years ago yes
yeah and I never understood until three
years ago the whole time you thought
this man was your father yeah but I mean
he wasn't around either so so you
weren't like having interactions with
him not really and and I would visit him
and stuff like in China and he never
told you he didn't no what he didn't
know it does no one ever got tests or
anything he did I don't think he wanted
to believe it I think he knew deep down
but I think he wanted to think that that
I was his daughter so what how and why
do you find out in the pandemic
my mom because everybody thought I knew
already
yeah and my mom realized she didn't tell
me she [__] forgot the [__] forgot
what are you talking about this [__]
forgot to tell me Andrew you know what I
forgot to tell you who your dad is
23 years old I mean it's honestly so uh
it's so her though to forget to tell me
it's like I can't even like but how's it
come up what happened it popped it off
where my she was she FaceTime my birth
father they they talk regularly and I
think at one point I think I was still
calling addressing him like like a uncle
or something and then he brought it up
to her out loud when you heard it or no
no no no privately because my dad my
birth father is actually a sensitive
person like I I which I've always you
mean somebody in this whole story cares
I know all right I mean he's not he's
not been around he's been married to
someone else so I don't know how much
she's got some compassion and empathy
yeah someone that cries a lot and I am
too so I always was like where did I get
that from nobody else in my family like
has emotions where did I get this like
sensitive like just soft side from and
it's my dad do you look more like your
mom or your dad I look like a mix of
bugs yeah but I think more my mom yeah
but
so she he brought it up to her and was
like why is she still calling me like
you know God like because
his role is like Godfather kind of
like why is he she's still addressing me
as that and then she was like oh she
doesn't know I guess and then my dad was
he shocked yeah my birth father was like
I thought you [__] told her like it's
been so long there's no reason for her
not to know at this point and she was
like you're right
and so she told me because it was just
so late
I was
what's on brand for I want to hear how
your mom it is
her face was all weird I remember I knew
I when I saw her face somewhere where
she in her house I was delivering uh
puppies from my dog my dog was having
puppies
it's such a stressful time you know what
I'm gonna hit her when the puppies start
coming out I know I was like Hey
speaking of birth I ever tell you who
your dad is
yo I did this
like having contractions and [__] and I
was like trying to focus I'm stressed
out my dog you know and uh and she's
like I have to tell you something I'm
like really what and her face was all
stressed out I knew she had something I
knew like right away did you have any
idea what it was no I was just scared I
was just like what are you about to tell
me right now and uh when she told me I
was shocked you were I really had no
idea even though I did look like this
guy like that's what I asked earlier
because I think it would be a trip if
you haven't met this man ever and then
all of a sudden whatever years later you
look at this person like Jesus Christ
that looks like me you know I think that
would be a bit of a mind [__] I don't
know why I didn't make that connection
like now that I see it you can see it
see it now I can't unsee it but before
it just just how did she say what'd she
say just that he's your dad he's your
biological father in such a stupid way
she was just like
your dad is not your dad
you know Greg's your dad right like what
no your dad's not your dad that's how
she starts yeah yeah
she said it's so stupid I remember I
wanted to smack her I was like what the
[__] do you mean like she she's like
your dad is not your dad and I was like
do stop with the riddles like can you
tell me like what what do you mean he's
like yeah your dad like she said his
name too she's like Aaron is not your
dad and then I was like uh-huh or like
what then who what do you mean I don't
understand and she was like yeah he
didn't he's not your dad and say okay
well who's my dad and he's like she said
um
yeah she said she said
my birth father's name and then
um I remember just being like what
and it took me a second
and
I cried a lot
and she was like why are you crying are
you serious yeah she's like why are you
crying like she started kind of being
like why are you having such a reaction
you know
and I was like I don't know okay like
like because I was trying to justify I
actually don't know I mean it is an
emotional moment I just there's a lot
going on there's a lot going on also
like this person betrays your trust and
you know you're just like Jesus Christ
you give a [__] about me at all lady
yeah and but I was just trying to
justify this emotions to her and then I
was like who else
worried about Pingo oh my God my dog and
but uh my dog's fine like but she
I was crying and I was like who who else
knows and she's like everyone
that's the worst I know everyone you
were the last to find out who your dad
was yeah that's crazy yes I was pissed
and I was like I was like Grandma and
Grandpa know and they're like yeah yeah
yeah
I was like oh and and then she told me
right away she's like they wanted me to
get rid of you I it was almost a job I
think she did it that's when you found
that part out too I think she couldn't
wait to tell me I think it was a job
because I think she's like I think she's
always been jealous of how close my
grandparents are with me because they
didn't give her that love and then for
me I love my grandparents more than my
mom yeah
or like at least we're closer I love
them all equally really but we are
closer as so I think she wanted a little
dig and she was like yeah they didn't
they didn't want me to keep you I gotta
knock them down yeah a couple pigs
exactly no yeah and so and I was like oh
and that hit me too now I'm crying
oh my God yeah
so
no she's cold she's cold she's
cold-blooded
um but she I yeah and
listen your dad ain't your dad I gotta
get back to the casino yeah yeah she's
like hurry I gotta I gotta that's a lot
but uh yeah and I was just like crying
and crying and then uh it took a while
for me to get through that
just the shock of it and then I
facetimed with my birth father for the
first time yeah tell me about this not a
word like not a word we just both start
crying and then Dutch and I was like
that's my dad
because he's showing emotion he's not
asking why you're crying he's crying
with you exactly and so what was that
like it was memorable I remember like I
it was it stuck with me just like this
person that was so moved in the same way
as me because I never saw myself in the
rest of my family everybody else like
things got to me a lot deeper I was way
more sensitive than everybody else or at
least like for them if things got to
them they'd suppressed they repressed it
down and it came out in anger but I had
sadness in me and so um and anger but uh
but I saw I remember just being like Oh
that's me you know I remember seeing
myself in a family member for the like
one of the first times basically so
um did you yeah did you feel seen did
you feel heard I I was
I think it's the first thing you said to
him
you say hi Dad yeah did you no I said no
I I didn't because I don't think I was
ready but I said
I think I just made some noise I was
like oh like you know I just some sounds
managed to make it out words did not
because I was just like
crying yeah so
yeah I was very emotional and then my my
mom was like witnessing all of this and
because she was holding the phone
and and I remember what the [__] are you
two crying about no that's exactly what
she did wow yeah she like
[Laughter]
come on man they're waiting for me down
at the table no I'll never forget her
face too looking over at her watching us
cause she's confused she really was she
was like are you guys like so emotional
and I was like Mom can you just get out
here like I can't and
um
yeah so so that that was the face time
but I haven't seen him in person yet uh
ever no no no like since finding out
really yeah why do not want to visit do
you not have the desire are you not like
I'm too busy here yeah like because I
started stand up already when she told
me and things were picking up and then I
moved after the pandemic to La so it
just I just you were here you can't
really round everything out oh I was in
uh Vancouver during the pandemic when I
found out and then I moved right when I
could
because I just wanted to uh I felt
behind because of the pandemic and being
Canadian and so
excuse me and so we went so I just had
no time I really just had no time to go
visit and he can't come because he's
working in China so
yeah oh he's in China yeah that's fine
if he was in if he was in in the North
America I would definitely have is he
watching any of your clips and stuff so
you know what you do no he has no access
to it but he knows that I do stand up
and he's like proud of me but he's
always been like you don't have to do
anything okay like if you don't want to
just be happy just be happy like he's
he's supportive of like whatever
um
yeah and I think about him and it's like
he says all these things and he's
supportive but he was never here so I
feel like it's like easy to do say all
those things and I could only give him
so much credit you know yeah yeah
so
um
so tell me about let's see have you
battled addiction or anything like that
yourself no but I think I have it in me
I have like a DNA wise like I definitely
have an addictive personality I probably
would like I've had those like stupid
app games and I played game I used a
game a little bit I would just like get
really into it and spend money on it and
I I see the demons in me like peep out
and I shut that down right away so I
don't do anything I don't drink I don't
do drugs I don't smoke weed I don't do
anything do you worry about that I worry
about it yeah what's your Vice then
I waved for like four months and then I
stopped that's not yeah you're good yeah
yeah I think we're okay but I um what if
you shop do you I used to have a
shopping thing I used to spend way too
much money but I also I'm good at
self-control like once I decide to stop
it's it's finished yeah
maybe like eating late night I don't
know like just yeah but our job is weird
yeah I know Kirsten goes with me all the
time and I'm like let's [__] figure
out what we want between these next
shows because if we don't we're gonna
beat these goddamn mozzarella sticks I
know pretzels it's so hard to not eat
late at night after the show you're
starving I just worked all night we're
not eating during the show so yeah yeah
I can't go over
them that's gross I'll fall asleep yeah
yeah
so I don't really I guess like
relationships I I my I might have been
addicted to like chasing love or
something but it never took over my life
I for a while when I was younger and I
didn't know I didn't love myself enough
I was maybe chasing the approval of
people that didn't deserve it but
probably modeled after how my mom and my
relationship was
um so how do you deal with the all of
this like I'm this is
such not a normal [__] story
obviously yeah you wouldn't be here if
you had one and how do you deal with the
mental health uh
uh struggles of all of this do you go to
therapy no because I don't enjoy it it
makes me feel like I'm
validating the problems too much
that's an interesting you know what I
mean like I did for a while and but then
I remember being like you're giving it
too much it makes it too real yeah yeah
because if I it's not like I'm
suppressing it's not like I'm pushing
the problems down it's more so I'm
I'm not allowing it to be a problem
because if I if you think about anything
too much it can become a problem 100 you
saw a future tripping on it and
everything exactly so I felt like
therapy was doing that so instead of
dwelling on problems and talking about
it I would I started just to learn to
like work on myself and love myself like
take care of my body eat well
um be around people I love and uh love
talking to and make me feel like high
energy afterwards
and just like protecting myself from
people that hurt me
um
and being more present in the moment
that helped me more than therapy ever
has yeah okay yeah
um and not to get into your personal
life but when you have relationships or
if you're in one now and stuff do you
how long do you wait to tell your
partner about your past and how you
write like has have any of your
significant others ever met your mom or
your grandparents yeah
it's horrible I am I learned now that
unless it's very serious they're not
gonna meet my family and why what is it
my mom is
my mom is a my mom
will judge them right away but the worst
parts of them and say it in front of me
and the person no but like in Mandarin
so that they don't understand but it's
still like you're still insulting the
person I'm stating
um I would also just being an insecure
person I would assume that if you're not
saying any language I understand it's
not positive you know what I mean
exactly exactly yeah exactly oh it just
filtered like honestly good so it's rude
right away it's just rude and so so that
makes me upset and then excuse me and
her always her first thing is like does
dude they have money you know so she
still has that mindset yeah he she told
me she's like if you're dating someone
and they're not paying for for you or
whatever for everything or or he's not
giving you money then you're a stupid
girl
you would you're just a stupid stupid
girl you know like how do you feel about
that now like if you go on the polar
opposite like I'm gonna be [__] into
like does it drive you to be different
what is that how does that mindset
affect you yeah it made me like
devalue it made me like want to put
money last
you know and uh
I still
need it and pursue it but like in
another person I don't that's not like
right one of the first things I look for
so I did go the other way and uh so you
genuinely don't care if the person you
date is uh
you know I don't want you know does
isn't a millionaire isn't saying here
here's [__] a thousand dollars go
shopping with your friends oh for sure I
don't care I really don't care and to
speak to that I dated a comedian for
five years so I really don't care yeah
your mom would have been like I'm a
shady no I'm not always pissed she was
pissed I dated him for five years like
yeah it was um
yeah no but let me ask you this your
mom's mindset I'm just curious
if slash when you marry does your mom
expect that husband to not only take
care of you but to also kick her some or
is yes she does oh first I feel like an
addict and I get like what what is he
doing for me too it's not just you
I was just gonna say that is something
that's why I don't introduce whoever I'm
dating to my mom anymore because she'll
immediately be like can they help me
with something like not not money but
just like can they work right like can
they work in my shop can they drive this
to another city can they somehow help me
in any way and I'm like I started seeing
this person maybe for a month can we
please they're not about to be your work
like I got mad at her I like fought with
her about it I was like don't have these
expectations of someone we're just
getting to know each other you know so
she's always thinking who can benefit
her you know and it bleeds into the
people I'm dating too so yeah now I
learned to not definitely not introduce
um to her right it's again a very
personal question you don't have to
answer if you don't want to but if again
slash when you have kids are you gonna
let them meet Mom yeah here's the thing
I think with in Asian culture we're very
family oriented I will always like love
and take care of my mom I will always
want her near maybe not too near but
like but like your kids are going your
kids are going to be at the casino what
on her front one on her back cigarette
like let's go double down
[__] that insurance I
oh no I
no but I I always like
fantasized about like you know become
becoming very successful and then buying
her a home a few streets down
yeah yeah yeah
and then she'll she can walk over when
she wants to you know
um but just a little bit of distance but
I love her still and I will I tell her
all the time I'm like I'm gonna take
care of you like don't worry stop
whatever overthinking hear this and that
because she's always been insecure about
it she always thinks I don't love her
and she she starts fights a lot when she
feels threatened by my like questioning
if I love her or not and she starts like
yeah it comes out in anger her her
insecurity about my love for her and I
remember just like crying a lot and
being like no I love you like I do I
really love you and I think you love me
too but I don't think you like me
I said that to her
um
she like ignored it but yeah she's like
I don't like what you're saying
yeah yeah she's like I don't like this
conversation
um
this has been a great episode it's a
very different story and especially I
want to ask you this now because I'm
trying to do the timeline in my head but
I told you about 16 year old me and you
said your mom left the husbands around
14 so your grandparents so this is
probably close to around the time your
grandparents come to America when you're
around 16 isn't it like pretty close
yeah yeah yeah so what advice would you
give to 16 year old Andrea oh 16 I was
watching a lot of High School Musical
and and reading Twilight oh yeah I was
so into Twilight oh my God I think
I was in there
I bought okay my advice would be to
start stand up as soon as you can that
was like that saved my life I think
stand-up saved my life like because my
family was crazy and I hated how much uh
I had how different my life was from
everybody else's I just wanted a normal
life I just wanted to eat mac and cheese
or whatever yeah you know whatever other
kids are doing I just want that's all I
wanted but now with stand up I'm
thankful for my experiences I that I
lived through them and became the person
I am
um
and
I'm thankful for my unique life now so
that I could talk about it and I could
write about it you know and I could
create
projects and or whatnot like stand up
about it so uh I would tell her to look
into doing stand up and don't be afraid
yeah
good for you thank you for doing this I
really appreciate you coming on thank
you for having me this was great um plug
and promote everything again yeah let's
try this one more time
uh I'm going on tour I am doing a Texas
ride I'm doing a lot of East Coast uh
Utah I'm doing Ohio bunch of dates
Springfield the Missouri Bloomington uh
all you can find it all on angiogen.com
and follow me on social media at Andrea
jyn on Instagram at Andrea gin1 on Tick
Tock there it is all right thank you
very much thank you and as always thank
you guys come out see me on tour all
tickets are available at ryancicle.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
foreign